let's talk about the 14 things you can
consume to make fasting much easier
realize that when you do fasting
anything that you're consuming other
than water is going to break your fast
to some degree but these are the items
that will have a very very minor effect
on your ability to get right back into
fasting and when we're talking about
fasting we're talking about lowering
your ketosis we're talking about raising
insulin that type of thing and obviously
the biggest thing that will break your
fast is refined carbohydrates or sugar
okay the high carbohydrate diet protein
also has the ability to break your fast
because protein can stimulate insulin
and a good portion of protein actually
turns into fuel in your body and this is
why if you're doing fasting and then
let's say you work out and you take some
branched chain amino acids right before
the workout during your fast you will
break your fast because that would
stimulate glucose or collagen or bone
broth those will actually increase
insulin now the two things that don't
seem to have that much effect on insulin
our fats and fiber fiber has a zero
effect on insulin so when you're
consuming leafy greens for example that
are very high in fiber low in sugar that
will have a very minimal effect on
insulin but on the flip side of that
anything that you eat in general of any
significance if it has a certain
quantity of calories can stimulate
insulin to a certain degree so that
being said let's just go through the
things that you could consume that will
have a minimal effect on your ability to
stay in ketosis and do your fast now
number one MCT oil this is very very
good especially when you're starting out
especially in the morning maybe to put
in your coffee because MCT oil will turn
into ketones very very fast and then
your brain can run on the ketones your
heart can run on the
you're you can use these ketones as
energy and MCT oil will allow you to go
longer without getting hungry so that
would be number one number two coffee
coffee does not have a lot of calories
and it doesn't seem to break the fast
very much so coffee would be okay
as long as you don't put sugar in it now
if you add an alternative sweetener
maybe a little wreath or tall or stevia
or a monk fruit that would be totally
fine but let's say for example you want
to add whole cream so a little bit of
whole cream will have a very minor
effect and I wouldn't worry about it too
much so coffee can help you
fast longer it can reduce hunger number
three exhaustion is ketones another name
for this would be ketone salts so let's
say for example you're fasting and you
feel tired or you have brain fog you can
basically just take ketones and they go
into your blood and then your brain will
pick it up because if the brain has a
choice between glucose or ketones it'll
always pick ketones but if your body has
not adapted yet and you haven't
generated the ketones you can end up
with low blood sugar and you might feel
kind of funky and tired but if you
provide the key talents for the brain it
will suck them up and use them for brain
energy so this could help you feel
better while you're fasting especially
with brain fatigue or lethargy number
four tea drinking tea can greatly help
you go longer when you fast especially
with the phytonutrients in the herbs
that make up the tea number five
electrolytes by taking certain minerals
and realize there's hardly any calories
in here unless you're getting the wrong
type of electrolytes that has a glucose
in it which we never recommend but the
minerals the trace minerals and
electrolytes will actually help your
blood sugars and help your energy of
your muscles and it just makes it easier
to do fasting number six probiotics
probiotics are healthy bacteria that it
can help stabilize blood sugars alright
number seven B vitamins B vitamins will
help insulin resistance it will give you
energy
so these B vitamins are needed at the
cellular level especially when you're
doing fasting or ketosis all right apple
cider vinegar has a great effect on your
blood sugars and it can allow you to go
a lot longer without eating now if
you're doing kombucha tea a lot of times
they have a bit too much sugar in that
product so you want to read the labels
if you find one with two grams that
might be okay but even two grams
could be too much for some people so it
really depends on your 'men your
metabolism but I will say that generally
speaking this is lower amounts of sugar
than other types of tea and it has a
good probiotic and a good acid to help
you go longer especially at night let's
say your you want a replacement for beer
or wine or champagne this has a similar
texture and carbonation that can act as
a substitute number nine fiber fiber
does not stimulate insulin and it's food
for your microbes and the microbes
actually make butyric acid which is
actually kind of a in the family of
ketones and that can help stabilize your
blood sugars and improve insulin
resistance so if you were to do a
concentrated green fiber or a wheatgrass
juice powder that usually should be
totally okay because you get the
nutrients from it and if you're doing a
greens drink with fiber the fiber
actually can act as food for your
microbes so that would be something that
could enhance things because you're it's
almost like you're consuming a
dehydrated form of a vegetable and you
can even feel more satisfied with that
all right number 10 arethe rotol so you
can put that in your coffee but a wreath
or tall has a zero effect on the
glycemic index so it gets absorbed in
the small intestine and it gets in the
blood and it gets pushed out the kidneys
unchanged so it's a sweetener so if you
were to add that with the tea or the
coffee whatever that would be fine or
stevia or monk food these three
sweeteners do not have hardly any
effects on your blood Sugar's number 11
lemon juice now there is a little bit of
car
in lemon juice but a little lemon juice
in your water is totally fine and for
the most part it really won't break your
fast for more than a minute okay but it
can actually help reduce the risk of
kidney stones and even gout or high
levels of uric acid all right number 12
amino acid blend so protein in general
will stimulate insulin but there are
certain blends of amino acids like the
keto essential amino acids that have an
effect of not providing fuel for the
body but mainly for recovery so straight
amino acid blend you can have a great
effect right after you workout to give
you certain amino acids without giving
you that insulin spike if you want more
information I put a link down below all
right number 13 is sea salt this is very
very important I recommend the Himalayan
pink sea salt that would be something
that I really like but sea salt actually
can make you actually feel stronger your
muscles it can help with your energy
level because if you're deficient in
salt you can have like the keto flu or a
keto fatigue so this could give you more
energy and lastly number 14 is just
water now not just recommending drinking
massive amounts of water like gallons to
somehow satisfy you but I will say that
when you're doing fasting if you're a
stone former and you develop kidney
stones you may find that your uric acid
goes up and potentially you could form a
uric acid stone but if you're drinking
enough water I'm talking about 2 and 2.5
liters per day you're gonna pretty much
dilute the urine so you're not gonna
form a kidney stone so drinking more
water can help you now what are you
doing fasting you're gonna find that
you're gonna get a fluctuation in
hormones and when you get this
fluctuation you may go through a little
bit of hunger at certain points
especially in the morning at 8 o'clock
when you have a little spike of cortisol
and you might feel like you need to eat
if you just ignore that
transient hunger that will go away in
most cases but if it persists then go
ahead and eat but if you're going
through a little wave of I'm a little
hungry and Alice said it goes away just
realize that is just a hormonal flux and
you should want to ignore it and push
through that and go a little bit longer
alright thanks for watching so what does
this say thank you so much for watching
my videos I really really appreciate it
now if you have benefited from my
information or videos and want to share
it with the world
I would love to have you run up a
success story so click the link down
below fill it out and let's let people
know the benefits of healthy keto and in
a minute fasting
you